So what I want to do today,
again,
this is a parallel holding pattern lecture.
I'm going to talk about absolute rule and this parallels what's you're reading.
It's just to make clear,
uh,
with some emphasis about the importance of the development of,
of absolute rule.
Now,
one of the points I made last week,
for those of you who were here,
uh,
I is that,
you know,
one of the themes that ties European history together and,
uh,
is,
the growth of,
of the modern state of state making is,
tends to be an awkward expression or term that is used by,
uh,
by historians.
Um,
and if you look at the way states are,
uh,
in Europe now,
whether it'd be relatively decentralized,
such as,
as,
as Great Britain or extraordinarily centralized as,
uh,
my France,
the,
the origins of the modern state,
uh,
must impart,
be seen in this kind of remarkable period of,
of a European history,
uh,
from the early 17th century through the middle of the 18th century.
Now,
there were a,
we have a process in late medieval Europe of the consolidation of,
of,
uh,
of territorial monarchies.
I mean,
you did have monarchies like Spain,
England,
and France.
Namely,
those were the,
the three most important ones that,
that in which rulers consolidated,
brushed to claimants to power aside and,
uh,
consolidated,
their,
uh,
their rule.
But the period of absolute rule really a comes,
uh,
begins really in the mid 17th century,
and is to be found in those states that had specific kinds of,
of,
of social structures.
And this is a point we'll come back to a particularly when we're talking about,
uh,
the two most important states,
two of the,
of the great powers of the period that did not have absolute a rule.
Uh,
and in which in the case of of England,
uh,
the civil war was,
was largely fought,
eh,
to have to great extent anyway,
trying to prevent England,
I think.
Which monarchy from taking on characteristics of those absolute,
those emerging absolute states on the continent.
And I'll talk next Wednesday about English and British slash.
British cause Britain doesn't exist.
Those 1707,
uh,
self identity and how not being an absolute state is part of what a emerged in
the sense of being British and being Dutch.
Certainly,
arguably even more,
uh,
had had to do a with that because of the proximity of,
of the direct threat to the Dutch by,
uh,
by the,
the megalomaniac,
uh,
Louis the 14th who a modestly referred to himself as,
as,
as the sun king.
Um,
so between 1650,
uh,
and 1750,
and it says right out of what you're reading,
uh,
the rulers of continental Europe of the biggest states extended their power.
Um,
and so there were two aspects of this.
One is they extend their ability to extract resources out of their own
populations.
And second,
uh,
they,
they worked to,
uh,
increase their dynastic holdings at the expense of their neighbors munching
smaller states,
uh,
or in a by marriages or by wars against their big arrivals.
I mean,
one of the most interesting examples of that is the 30 years' war,
which starts before this course and ends before this course were really with the
beginning of this core 16,
18,
16,
48,
which I'm going to come back to a little bit,
uh,
in,
in a while,
is that what begins as,
uh,
as,
as a religious war between Protestants and Catholics,
uh,
ends up being a dynastic struggle between two Catholic powers,
consolidating their authority over their own peoples and expanding their
dynastic domains,
thus Austria,
uh,
and uh,
and France.
And so that tells you that's an important point because it tells you what really
the big picture is going to,
um,
is going to emerge.
And so when we're talking about the growth of absolute rule,
we're talking about France.
That is,
you know,
the sun king pressure,
particularly Frederick the great,
uh,
about whom you can read Russia,
Peter,
the grade about whom I will,
um,
have,
have something to say in a week or two.
I don't know.
When Austria,
aforementioned and Sweden and Sweden kind of disappears from the great power
stage,
uh,
when they're defeated by Peter,
the great,
uh,
in,
when is it?
1709.
Now what did it mean to be an absolute ruler?
What it meant was that in principle,
uh,
your power was a greater than,
than any challenge that could come from,
you know,
those,
those underlings,
those craven reptiles and your imagination over whom you ruled.
Um,
but there's a balance to it that,
that I'll,
I'll discuss,
uh,
in a while.
Um,
uh,
and so there,
there,
there isn't really can't be a challenge to them from the state,
uh,
themselves.
And so they make their personal or dynastic rule absolute based on loyalty to
them as individuals.
Uh,
and not to,
uh,
the state has some sort of abstraction.
Of course,
one of the interesting things that we'll hear about a in a couple of days is the
fact that that British national identity,
which is formed precociously early in European history,
uh,
a arguably in the 17th century and,
and suffer elites perhaps even before,
uh,
has this sort of constitutional balance between the rights of parliament,
victorious in the,
in the,
in the English civil war,
uh,
and loyalty to,
to the monarchy now.
Um,
so absolute rulers assert their,
their right to make laws to reclaim,
to announce laws with a wave of their,
of their,
uh,
a chubby hands,
to levy taxes,
uh,
and,
to appoint Fischels who will carry out their will.
So,
I mean,
it's possible to talk about the bureaucratization of medieval states if you
want,
but it's still,
it's when you look at the long range,
a growth of bureaucracies as part of government,
as part of state formation.
That's why,
uh,
you know,
the,
the growth of these bureaucracies is one of the characteristics of these
absolute states in all of these,
these big time,
uh,
powers.
Um,
and so,
uh,
what they do is,
is,
well,
let me give you a couple of examples.
I mean,
for one more thing absolute monarchs don't want is they don't want impediments
to their personal rule.
Now,
what was the kind of an impediment to their personal rule?
One would be handsy.
What would be the municipal privileges?
For example,
in the German port towns,
uh,
you know,
Lubeck and Homburg and the others,
they formed this Hanseatic League,
uh,
and Germany,
remote remains decentralized.
There's all sorts of states.
Some are more powerful than others,
but Germany is not unified until 1871.
Um,
but if you go to,
if you think of Spain,
if you need to be hitchhiking through Spain or something like that,
or,
uh,
or through the south of France or Europe passes,
and if you go to a town like Aviva,
a in Spain,
I mean,
I realized one of the most fantastic,
uh,
you know,
fortified wall towns in,
in,
in Europe,
or if you're going to need him in the south of France and new,
you'll see boulevards that people raise motorcycles around all the time.
We'll keep you up all night.
Uh,
there are no walls there anymore because the king had them knocked down.
And so what happens with miscible privileges,
towns that had been this full privileges,
uh,
these are,
roaded and then virtually eliminated by powerful potentates.
In the case of Neem and I am a e which was a Protestant town,
they knocked down the wall.
So the Protestants have,
nene could not defend themselves against this all conquering Catholic monarch.
And so municipal privileges,
walls were put up for a variety of reasons around towns.
You know,
playing for example,
you know,
Dubrovnik,
one of my favorite cities in Europe,
Dubrovnik had these magnificent walls.
You can walk all the way round and they have a quarantine house where they would
put people who are travelers arriving there because walls kept out plagues
walls.
Uh,
keep out,
Matt said to him,
you know,
evil doers,
I,
they keep out bandits and things like that.
And the doors literally slam shut at night.
There was a case of a very minor insurrection in an obscure Italian city in,
in the,
uh,
18,
in 1848 where the,
the,
the people of the town literally locked,
uh,
the rule out of the town.
Now,
what,
uh,
in Italy remains,
you know,
the tradition of these central of these decentralized city states that were the
heart of the renaissance,
Italy is not unified to the extent it was ever been unified,
uh,
until the 18,
16 and 1870s.
So,
uh,
what,
what the,
what these kings do,
uh,
these kings and that,
you know,
these,
uh,
and in Queens is they,
they,
uh,
get rid of these impediments to their,
to their,
uh,
to their authority.
I even take the word Burger,
a burger or bourgeois.
Bourgeois is the French word is more of a cultural sense,
but also as a class sense,
a bourgeois or a burger with somebody who lived in a city and was a,
and w w assume that some of the justice that was levied against him or her,
uh,
would be,
the result of,
of,
of decisions taken locally and now big time.
A big powerful absolute monarchs don't want that.
And so part of the whole process is the elimination of these,
uh,
these municipal,
privileges.
Um,
and so,
uh,
and replacing municipal officials to make a long story short with people that
they have,
uh,
appointed and they eliminate the one privilege above all that they want to,
the big guys want to get rid of is the,
is,
is the right to not be taxed.
Peak is part of being an absolute ruler,
uh,
is being able to levy taxes against,
against those,
uh,
of those people who have the,
the joy or the extreme misfortune of living,
uh,
in,
in those domains.
And more about that later.
But,
so what happens with all of this is that absolute rule impinges directly on the
lives of ordinary people,
more than then kingly or Queen Lee or princely or Archbishop Lee Power had,
uh,
had intruded on the lives of ordinary people,
before that.
And so,
I mean,
these rulers have a course of ability in trading.
I'll come back to this large standing armies that will be arriving,
not immediately.
They're not arriving by train or being Hilo Copter and in at some dissident
command,
but they will get there.
If there's trouble,
they will arrive and they will get,
they'll get there and they will enforce the will of the monarch.
Uh,
and we'll see.
The statistics are really just fascinating about how big these armies,
uh,
become.
Um,
and so the argument that I'm going to make drawing upon again,
Ted Rab Theater rebs,
uh,
he's not the only one who made this argument,
but he's made that more clearly than that.
And most people,
absolutism may be seen as a,
as an attempt to reassert a public order and coerce of state authority after
this period of utter turmoil.
The English civil war,
the,
uh,
the 30 years' war in which parts of central Europe,
a quarter of the population disappeared,
were killed,
murdered in ways that I will unfortunately show you in a while.
Uh,
and um,
more than this,
uh,
what,
what happens is that these,
that,
that the nobles who in all these countries going back to the medieval period had
had privileges that they were asserting visa vi their monarchs.
They will say,
ah,
we will agree to be junior partners and absolutism in exchange for the
protection that you,
the big guy and your armies can provide us so that we don't have to lie awake
wondering who is coming up the path to the big house.
Is it peasants who are going to come and assert,
uh,
you know,
the rights of the poor against us.
And at a time of insurrections in a popular insurrections and all sorts of
countries,
think of all the instructions of all the people that followed faults as ours to
other slaughter and,
and Russia,
uh,
that,
that the Nobel say,
all right,
we agree to be junior partners and absolute rule,
uh,
in exchange to recognize in your supreme authority over us and exchange for the
protection of that,
that you will afford us.
You know,
private armies are disappearing.
The armies of the state,
or as you'll see in a while are,
are,
are growing.
And Moreover,
you,
oh,
big guy,
you will,
will assert our pro,
our own privileges.
You will recognize our privileges as nobles.
And so it's a trade off,
but an absolute states,
there's no doubt who rules and who helps rule.
And so I an absolute states,
uh,
you know,
big noble families are very happy to send a their offspring,
uh,
to become a commanders in the army and navy are,
they never do a damn thing,
uh,
or to become big bishops like Talia Hall,
who was a teenage bishop,
uh,
you know,
literally,
uh,
and,
and to profit from,
uh,
from,
from the state while recognizing that the,
that the big guy,
the king and the queen have absolute authority over them.
Now,
the classic case of course,
Louis the 14th,
I mean,
you can read about now,
Louis the 14th,
when he was a kid,
he was about 12 or 13 years old.
He lived in Paris.
He lived,
uh,
in the [inaudible] palace,
which was burned along the cen,
which is burned in 18,
uh,
1871 during the commune.
And there was a huge old insurrection called the phone for,
and the IA phoned a kind of a slingshot that Paris street urchins used to use
to,
you know,
shoot fancy people with rocks as they rode their carriages,
uh,
through the muddy streets of Paris.
And it's a noble insurrection against royal authority.
And,
and in ovanion central France,
you have people rising up against their lords thing.
Hell with you.
We're not going to pay anymore.
And when he's a boy in,
he hears the crowd shouting outside of the royal palace in Paris and it scares
the hell out of them.
And at one time they burst into his bedroom and he's a little guy.
And when he,
when Royal Authority conquers these rebels,
the phone,
Duh,
you don't have to memorize that,
but the F R and d when it's good that,
you know,
for cocktail party conversation or something like that,
but it's uh,
it's important.
He makes them literally,
he's a bigger guy.
Then they literally come and they bowed down and they,
they swear allegiance to him in exchange for protection and the recognition of,
uh,
of their privileges as nobles is titled,
Nobles.
And so that's really that finding moment in,
in,
in absolute rule.
And so what does,
what does Louis the 14th do?
Well,
he goes out and built Versailles and he only goes back to Paris,
I think three times ever.
He doesn't like Paris and Versailles is only 18 kilometers away.
It's about 11 or 12 miles away.
The women of Paris in October,
many of them are walk devel sy to bring the king back to Paris.
And after that he's essentially,
well put it kind of ridiculous like toast and French toast,
uh,
when,
when that happens.
But so he builds this big week,
I've called it a noble theme park,
basically,
uh,
Advil sign.
It's not the most interesting of the chateau at all.
The most interesting as Volvo v COMP,
which is,
is,
uh,
southeast of,
of Paris.
But it's a big sort of sprawling of gardens everywhere.
10,000 nobles live there.
How boring.
But the point was that they could,
they could be watched that they're not gonna,
you know,
they can chase each other's wives and mistresses around,
uh,
and they can eat big drunk in meals.
The Chateau was so big that when it is,
freezes,
they,
you know,
they would walk,
they were trying to get to the bathroom and most of them never made it and sort
of peed on these long corridors.
It,
some of you have seen in the wine would freeze on the way from the kitchen to a,
it has said,
uh,
to,
you know,
to the,
the big dining hall.
Uh,
but he has 10,000 of these dudes and dudettes is there that he's going to watch
over so that they can,
they can conspire against each other and they can hit on each other's wives and
mistresses.
He could give one damn,
but,
but he can control them there.
And he knew he only goes back to Paris three times ever.
All the time.
He's expanding his own part,
personal power,
visa vi the,
uh,
his own population and,
you know,
conquering a Alsace and parts of the hand and,
and,
uh,
you know,
going to these navigable,
natural frontiers.
I'm an employee in thought,
the natural for tier with the Pacific Ocean.
Uh,
you know,
that would be another story.
But,
but,
but so this is what,
in a nutshell,
kind of what absolute TISM was.
But Let,
let me say two things now after having said that,
that,
um,
there were,
there are doctrines and you can read about this stuff even mean Jesus obvious,
but,
but there were doctrines of,
of absolutism that originated with jurists early.
I mean,
so this was out there.
There was a theoretical conceptual framework for having a king or queen having
absolute,
uh,
powers.
Um,
and,
um,
the,
even the development of this theory of absolute rule is in response to,
uh,
the rise of these territorial states like Spain and France and,
and well Russia,
uh,
later.
Uh,
uh,
and,
so,
uh,
Francis is a good example.
I quote in here,
a guy who croaks before this course starts,
but as you want,
we'll go down a,
B,
O,
d,
I.
N he says,
seeing that nothing upon earth is greater or a higher next unto God than The
Majesty of kings and sovereign princes.
He wrote in six books of the republic.
The principal point of Sovereign Majesty and absolute power was to consist
principally and giving laws,
dictating laws onto the subjects in general without their consent.
So for absolute rulers,
I mean the,
the link to religion you can read about,
but there's always the sense that he or she is doing God's will,
uh,
by,
by exploiting exploiting ordinary peasants,
ordinary people,
and conquering other territories.
But,
but there's a theoretical framework that,
that,
uh,
well in and we'll catch up with,
with,
with a French monarchs,
uh,
among others,
later,
uh,
that,
that father,
the ruler must be a father,
a benevolent figure.
I mean,
as I said in some contexts,
La last time,
I mean,
how many Russian peasants died in the 1890s thinking,
oh my God,
if this is our only knew that were starving,
how angry he would be with his officials.
Well,
if he could have given one damn how many millions of them died,
but this was the images that,
that,
that the big person is there to,
uh,
to protect you,
and uh,
and that his glory is your glory.
Um,
but along with this conceptual framework provided by none other than Thomas
Hobbs,
you know,
in,
in England who had lived through the English civil war and thought that you
shouldn't mess around with these,
this writes business,
you need some sort of big powerful,
uh,
a monarch there.
But there was a sense inherent in all of this,
and this will be important to try to understand the French revolution that
Rochelle phone says,
that there's a difference between absolutism and despotism.
And that even conceptually,
theoretically,
that if the monarch goes too far against the weight of the past,
that there is inherent in this,
the idea that he or she might will go.
And of course,
you can imagine the thoughts of Louis the 16th as they were cutting back his
hair,
uh,
to await the fall of the Guillotine on the 21st of January [inaudible] 17,
a 93,
uh,
and in the,
in the cafe and the Swa,
the bars of Paris,
which there are many,
many,
uh,
halfway.
So in 1789 when,
when ordinary people are drinking to the third estate and talking about
despotism and finding examples from what they saw around them as represented
despotic behavior,
that line had clearly been crossed and helps explain why it was that at a,
in a country in which there weren't 10 people who wanted republican 1789,
it was possible to imagine a life without a king.
You know,
imagine that.
So,
uh,
that,
that is,
that's there as well.
Now,
okay,
let's character old Jesus.
We've got to move here.
Um,
um,
let's characterize a absolute role.
Now,
you did have in many of these countries,
diets or parliaments,
uh,
some representative body,
but again,
the king doesn't have to call them.
In the case of France,
again,
since we're talking so much about,
about Louis the 14th,
uh,
they call this the state's general,
which is to represent all of the provinces after the execution.
After the assassination of,
of a Henry the fourth,
uh,
in 16,
10 or 16,
12 weeks,
appropriately enough,
he stabbed to death in a traffic jam in Paris.
When his carriage gets blocked in the middle,
in the center of Paris,
in,
in this mad monk,
uh,
sticks a big knife into them.
Uh,
and so they call the estates general then,
but the king never calls it again until 1789.
So you have these diets and have these parliaments.
But one of the characteristics of absolute rule,
uh,
is that you don't have to,
don't have to call these,
uh,
these bodies because the king is the big person.
Now,
in the case of England,
one of the causes,
English civil wars,
the refusal of,
of,
of uh,
uh,
the kings to pay to pay any attention to recognize the rights of parliament that
people in the British imaginary and the British,
uh,
a collective memory,
believe started on June 15th,
which my birthday,
1215,
though I wasn't born yet.
And in 1215,
uh,
and,
and so this,
the,
the idea of the free born English Person Englishman is what they would have said
in those days meant that parlors rights of parliament had to be respected.
And when it looks like they're going,
are they English kings are going to turn,
uh,
are going to restore Catholicism.
At least have lots of paintings of swooning,
cherubs and Cupid's and broke,
uh,
broke Italian in,
in,
uh,
in Windsor,
in London and these other places.
Well then you've got a revolution.
So,
um,
absolute rulers didn't really have to pay,
uh,
it didn't have to pay attention to these assemblies.
The best example I can think of off hand,
I should let this weight,
but,
uh,
Peter,
the great czar of the Russians who may or may not have beaten his son to death,
at least ordered them tortured.
Uh,
Peter the grade was a huge sort of power forward size guy.
at a time when people were,
were,
were very small.
He had this thing called the drunk and assembly,
which was in a way kind of a mockery of parliamentary representations where his
cronies would come and just get wasted.
Uh,
and,
and would make all sorts of sort of,
you know,
flamboyant proclamations that seemed to represent what,
what a real part of it would do.
But in fact,
Peter the great listen to whom he wanted to and ignored the others and sometimes
have them killed if you had to or if he thought that's what he should do because
there wasn't any sort of challenge to his authority and that my friends is part
of,
uh,
part of what it meant.
So,
um,
so already sent mentioned about how in a Jew nobles become partners,
junior partners in absolutism.
That's it.
Not a bad phrase,
junior partners and absolutism.
So what happens,
two ways of measuring how this happened and what difference it made is to,
is to realize that return to what I said earlier is that,
you know,
big state structures involve bureaucracies.
And so the king's representatives go out in the name of the king and they give
out justice or the lack of justice,
or they,
they,
they send armies in or taxes or this set of stuff.
Um,
now the renaissance city states in Italy had relative hit and we had relatively
efficient administrations to be sure,
but these are royal bureaucracies that expand dramatically in size.
And even though decentralized England expands is bureaucracy and collected taxes
much more efficiently than a across the channel they did in France,
uh,
there,
you know,
they were state making involve more officials there.
So in order to raise money,
you have to enforce taxes.
So you may form some taxes out to somebody who will keep as much of the cut as
they can possibly steal or to make money.
You'll sell noble titles and this gets the French kings in into,
uh,
into trouble or you sell monopolies.
And the Peter of the grade,
uh,
had a monopoly on dice cause people gambled a lot.
The nobles gambled all the time.
You could gamble serfs real people,
you could gamble them,
you can lose them with a bad hand.
Uh,
this,
you know,
this was Russia,
uh,
and,
and so the,
the monopoly on dice he sells,
he sells them monopoly on salt.
And salt was a big commodity y'all up for obviously for storing meet and that
monopoly is sold in various places.
Um,
and so these officials,
uh,
you know,
nobles get these kinds of official Rarey they can rake it in,
get these titles of,
and they are representing the king.
They're governors are intendance to call them in France.
Uh,
and,
uh,
um,
the,
the expand the numbers of,
of officials that dramatically,
um,
now and then there's warfare.
There was nothing more symptomatic of the growth of absolute rule.
Then,
uh,
the growth of powerful armies.
Again,
when you're traveling around Europe,
if you're lucky to do that,
uh,
you'll see these big fortified towns.
Uh,
in the case of France,
again,
uh,
they are the work of a brilliant military engineer called verbal Va.
You Ban and you go to a place like [inaudible] or Leila or Mommy D.
I mean,
they're all over the place.
And these are fortress like defenses in an age of essentially defensive warfare.
But if you're going to have a big old fort and you're going to have lots of
Canon that you hope to use against your craven,
a reptile enemies that would want to get in your way,
you're going to have people to try out the cannon.
You have to have people who live in these fortifications.
So the size of these armies for these megalomaniac wars,
these dynastic wars,
uh,
between Austria and,
and,
and uh,
uh,
France.
And then they changed partners,
uh,
in 1756 and all of this business,
you can read about that.
But the big story is huge,
huge,
huge amount of,
um,
of,
of troops.
Uh,
during the 16th century,
the peacetime armies of the continental powers were about 10 to 20,000 soldiers,
very,
very little.
By the 16,
nineties,
150,000 soldiers,
the French army,
which was then in 69,
he's 180,000 people.
That's twice Michigan Football Stadium.
If you imagine stadium packed with soldiers and all that,
how boring.
But anyway,
I had rose to 350,000 soldiers,
the largest in,
in Europe.
And I think I have in this edition of a table the size of European armies,
a half for Pyre,
1690,
50,000,
17,
56,
200,000.
A polyglot army too,
because of all the different nationalities,
Prussia identified with,
uh,
the Yonkers,
the nobles of who were army officers,
the dueling scars that they had at Bismark would have in a unified Germany.
Uh,
a mere 30,000 people in (690) 190-5000 people during the seven years' war in
1789,
190,000 in 18,
12,
as they're fighting Napoleon,
270,000 people.
And this isn't a state that barely extends beyond a Brandenburg and Pomerania a
in a what now is,
is a western Poland and,
uh,
and um,
and still pressure,
uh,
in the unified Germany.
Um,
even Sweden a hundred at the time of the battle of Poltava this,
they'll forget it,
but in 1709,
oh,
don't forget it,
but you know,
read about it.
1709,
uh,
that's when Sweden loses to Russia.
The Swedish army was 110,000 people.
Soldiers.
That's an awful lot.
So that's one of the things that happens.
Uh,
the modern state in a,
an action,
uh,
the absolute state in action is the army.
And,
and even in peacetime military expenditures take up almost half of the budget of
any European state.
And in times of war,
80%.
Now,
having said all that,
let me just,
oops.
Oops.
Okay.
I'll try and try to turn this baby on
that.
Go on.
Well,
isn't that go on.
Yeah,
I got a backup.
Oh,
I got to put this thing down.
That's it.
Yeah.
And again,
these just illustrate my point,
uh,
which is about why,
you know,
why did nobles and even other people agree to all of this?
Why do,
why do,
I mean,
you know,
if,
if they're being exploited,
if you've got big army,
it's like going to crush them like grapes if they get in the way.
Uh,
but,
but yet,
one argument that can be made is that things were so terrible and so out of
control,
uh,
in the earlier period of that,
the strengthening of the state is something that people saw as,
as,
as beneficial.
I mean you'd get a,
Hobbs is over the top.
I mean Hobbs wants to sort of dictatorship to keep people from brawling in the,
in the state of nature.
And again,
the elite in Britain was scared cause you've got all these ranter groups and
levelers and people believe that,
that everybody ought to have the right to vote where they have property or not.
And people that believe in the right of women.
I mean this was pretty scary.
Uh,
and so,
you know,
people like Hobbes thought,
well we need a really strong state,
but that's not the outcome of the,
of the English civil war.
But how did this work in,
um,
in other places?
Now I'm,
no theater wraps argument is basically that the terrible wars of religion,
uh,
that had ripped central Europe apart.
Uh,
uh,
in the middle of the 19th century,
led people to look for the kinds of,
of,
of uh,
safety provided by a strong a ruler.
A,
that what had begun,
and we'll see this in a minute as a war between Protestants and Catholics,
a war that began in Prague when somebody gets definitive fenestrated,
which is a,
is a fancy word for throwing somebody out of a window,
uh,
that this ended up being a war fought by just vicious mercenaries who
slaughtered the populations,
uh,
of central Europe.
It didn't matter if they were Protestants or Catholics or anything else,
they simply killed them.
Uh,
and that this terrified elites in much of Europe and had the same equivalent of
what the fund did for scaring a elites,
uh,
in France.
Um,
and that,
I mean,
one of the arguments that he makes,
and I can't make it as strongly because I don't know enough about the scientific
revolution,
what I know about is what you were kind enough to,
uh,
to read.
And it was hard to piece all this stuff together.
But there is this sort of sense of uncertainty that you see in a,
you know,
in,
in someone like the Kath who finally just goes back to basics and say,
well,
you know,
here,
I think,
no,
you're therefore,
I am.
I mean,
here I am.
Uh,
and,
and the go from there to a methodology of,
of science and methodology of,
of,
of trying to,
you know,
trying to study things in a rational way to,
to,
uh,
to get rid of the kinds of,
of blind faith that that seemed to have led to this,
this,
this is utter catastrophe of mass slaughter,
uh,
in Europe.
And so there's signs all over the place,
uh,
that this has happened.
I think therefore I am.
Um,
and there is a return to these kinds of,
of a theoretical defenses of,
of absolutism that even preceded,
uh,
the growth of the absolute state.
Uh,
as,
um,
as I've described it now,
absolutism did not simply just emerge out of this turmoil is that already
suggested.
And I would assist upon,
insist upon this again,
uh,
that the consolidation of territorial rulers had already given the basis to an
expanding more formalized state structure.
Uh,
even in,
uh,
even in England,
that,
that this,
this is for sure.
It all just doesn't start like that.
Uh,
Louis,
the 14th verse proceeded in number by read the 13th,
and Louis the 13th,
uh,
helps expand,
the compelling course of structures of,
of,
of the French state.
But yet,
yet when you look at all of this,
you can see that the,
the kind of chaos is the political upheaval,
upheavals,
uh,
finds in a response and the growth of central government authority and the
growth of bureaucracies.
And it wasn't only in Sweden,
Austria,
Russia,
France,
et cetera.
We found this even in smaller states like Virgin Berg,
a state in Germany,
which was,
uh,
you know,
sort of middle sized state.
Even there you see the same phenomenon on a very lower,
smaller level.
It leaves the leaves in terms of deaths of the size of the state,
where people are giving up,
willing to compromise on their,
their privileges in order for the protection of the ruler of earth and Berg who
would never be confused with Louis the 14th or Peter the Great.
But so this is really becomes a sort of European wide phenomenon and you can,
you can apply this also to the glorious revolution in England as well.
When people are,
you know,
they're happy to have a monarch back,
uh,
who's going to reassert control.
Uh,
and in the case of,
of England,
they're very happy to have a wide arc back who was not threatening to turn,
uh,
England again into,
into a,
a Catholic,
a Catholic state.
So this is the sort of,
um,
uh,
the,
the sort of,
uh,
argument,
that,
uh,
that you can make even in a state that had a constitutional monarch,
such as,
um,
uh,
such as England.
Now,
let me just give you a couple of examples of what one can mean here.
And again,
these are,
these are painters that you may have come across,
and it doesn't matter if you've never heard of them or if you never think of
them again,
but,
uh,
[inaudible] the famous,
Tieszen,
uh,
this is his picture of Charles the fifth at a battle in Germany in 1648.
And this is a pretty dramatic representation of war.
I mean,
this is like the hood is a clean Eastwood,
uh,
the good,
the bad,
and the ugly.
I mean,
this is a guy,
he's armored up.
He's ready to go.
He's somebody to be emulated,
uh,
from the point of view,
of,
uh,
of the viewer.
Um,
and,
uh,
but in,
at the same time,
I mean,
this is slightly earlier.
This is a painting.
Thanks Dan.
This is a painting of,
of,
uh,
[inaudible],
of the elder,
uh,
and,
and the first is,
is,
uh,
the triumph of the triumph of death.
Uh,
where you see a,
you know,
what happens in,
in real battle when people are just sort of slaughtered and the commanders are
off of the safe distance.
Uh,
and you know,
here again the massacre of the innocence.
We're villagers,
villagers or just being executed,
uh,
because,
their,
um,
and the massacre,
uh,
the,
the triumph of death,
uh,
you know,
the dialogue of the mathematician a pascal is quoted by Rab,
why are you killing me for your own benefit?
I am an armed why you do not live on the other side of the water?
My friend,
if you lived on this,
uh,
on this side I should be a murderer.
But since you live on the other side,
I'm a brave man and it is right,
uh,
that I kill you.
Uh,
and you know,
when the Swedes get into the act is to Alvis Adolphus,
uh,
you know,
brings this huge old Swedish army down and,
and you know,
they do a lot of damage to,
uh,
and people are absolutely,
being devastated.
Here's a Rubens of the horror of war.
Now there's a reason why the first attempt to even write about international law
comes at this period.
Uh,
again,
this is before the chorus,
but why not Hugo Gross?
[inaudible],
S he writes the Law of war and peace.
He publishes it in 1625.
The goal was to stop stuff like this,
to try to create a legal framework in which states could resolve their kind of,
of differences with all kind of butchering each other.
Uh,
and uh,
so there we go.
Um,
but it,
you know,
someone here in Warren piece of battle is,
is slowly being relegated to the background.
But let me give you another example of what people would,
you know,
here's a Hispanic famous painter,
a Spanish painter.
Again,
don't worry about it.
Of Alaska's a who died in,
in,
in uh,
what a 16,
16,
10 I think.
Yeah,
I think he died,
says no,
1660,
sorry.
This is his portrait of Mars.
Now Mars is the god of war.
Now,
how different that is than the portrait of teach the of Charles that you saw by
Titian.
Now here,
you know,
this guy looks like a kind of a,
an overweight NFL player who hasn't really got ready for the,
you know,
for the drill.
I,
he,
he's very human.
There's nothing sir admirable about them as this war is being dissed by those
people that just so tired of the killing.
Uh,
and Mars has this sort of human,
you know,
flabby torso that's not unsympathetic,
but it's a different portrayal of wars.
If people are getting tired of though of,
of,
of the whole damn thing,
he's doll,
he's uncouth.
Uh,
and he's extremely,
uh,
a human.
Now,
one of the,
you know,
the reasons why,
um,
you know,
why,
uh,
people would,
I mean,
it's unthinkable for someone like me or for probably most of you to imagine,
you know,
giving up your rights to kind of,
to kind of absolute rule that we seem to be in a situation like that where this
happened quite a lot,
uh,
recently,
even in his own country.
But,
uh,
um,
the,
these are just illustrations that come out of the 30 years' war,
which were what people are trying to put behind them.
This is by a,
this is a French,
uh,
paint or draw or lithographer,
called Ashoka Carlo.
Uh,
and,
uh,
these are just many ways that people died during,
during the 30 years' war.
Uh,
this is simply,
and this is the execution.
I mean,
you don't even need that,
the formal titles of these,
but these get around,
I mean,
peddlers who had these big,
big leather bags that would go around Europe and sell things like pins and,
and miraculous images of the Virgin Mary and the stories of saints and all this
kind of stuff.
And Joan of arc or a Robin Hood and the case of England,
uh,
you know,
part of it become part of the collective memory.
So these kinds of images do get around of the horrors of war,
uh,
that,
that the,
the misfortunes and the horrors of war,
which is basically what he calls us entire series.
And here's those peoples are sitting around watching this execution.
Uh,
is this somebody being tortured at the stake for merely existing,
uh,
for,
you know,
for having that,
uh,
confessed to being a protestant or a Catholic or,
or,
or whatever.
You know,
I'll tell you in the south of France near where we live,
there's this,
when there are a lot of resistance in World War II against the Germans,
there's some Protestant villages there that were noteworthy for the resistance.
A lot of Catholics resisted to.
But one of the interesting things about some of the villages that I know down
there is that there were a big mission crosses that were put out after the wars
of religion and these that were sort of symbols of conquest by the all Catholic
king.
Uh,
and those is it in the collective memory that people remember three centuries
later that the Catholic church was identified at least a hierarchy with,
with the Vichy regime and World War II.
You know,
it's,
that's interesting,
fascinating.
70.
But anyway,
this,
this poor guy,
he's not doing real well up there and it,
you know,
becomes a sort of big spectacle.
And here are some,
these are dying soldiers along the side of the road.
It's sort of a sympathetic look at,
that's the name of this,
uh,
of these,
expiring dudes there.
And here's the attack on a stage coach.
I mean,
the point of this,
it didn't matter who you were,
if you're in the wrong place at the wrong time,
you were,
uh,
you were a history that was all and there was new ways to be killed.
I mean,
certainly in Europe,
not until the massacre of the Armenians in 1895,
um,
and arguably some Napoleonic atrocities in an appointment armies,
atrocities in,
in Palestine or in a,
in the southern of Italy or in Spain as well.
But there was nothing like this,
uh,
really including world war one,
including some of the worst atrocities that were of world war one.
There was nothing like this again until World War Two.
Uh,
and of course,
of course,
Bosnia,
which at the point,
the point is that this is why lots of people thought,
you know,
I don't like this guy come in and sending people around,
taking my taxes.
But you know,
I don't want to get off by,
by some routers.
Are you,
can you hang 'em high?
You'd hang on,
hang them all.
Hi.
I mean,
these were real ways that people were,
were,
were executed.
Uh,
and uh,
uh,
just,
you know,
steaks,
massacres and this sort of business.
Uh,
there's a convent,
a church that's going to go,
uh,
if the Catholic church,
I can tell from the,
from the top,
maybe these are Protestant mercenaries.
It didn't matter because the Protestant armies had Catholic mercenaries and the
Catholic army said Protestant mercenaries and everybody held head Dalmatians,
people from the donation coast and Swiss,
you have to imagine a time in Switzerland.
It wasn't extremely wealthy.
Uh,
I,
and what we're Swiss were great,
you know,
famous mercenaries,
a fighting in these armies.
And again,
the Swedish,
the Swedish cocktail was sort of suffocating people by stuffing manure down
their throat until they died.
Uh,
you know,
uh,
this,
you know,
this was a nasty time.
This,
I guess this is what,
uh,
you know,
Hobbs met by nasty short and brutish or whatever the,
the fourth was,
I don't remember about what life was,
uh,
in the third years war.
That was the way it was.
Now,
out of all of this,
again to repeat,
uh,
we are not making the argument that the 30 years' war itself led to absolute
rule that,
that the growth of state structures can be seen in the beginning,
in the late medieval period with the consolidation of these territorial
monarchs,
uh,
monarchies.
Uh,
they were already bureaucrats representing the royal will.
there were already armies,
uh,
but many of us particularly to we were bureaucracies and,
and,
uh,
um,
and standing powerful standing military forces are characteristics of modern
states.
Uh,
and to try to explain why was that absolute rule came to Europe at the time it
did.
Uh,
one has to not only look at the particular,
uh,
particular structures of,
of states,
but when it has to look at,
at the overview and,
and this year,
you know,
the horror of it all.
Uh,
and you know,
the boy King Louis the 14th hearing the crowd shouting outside of his,
uh,
you know,
shouting outside of his room and he goes out to various size or creates this
noble theme park and it's over.
They,
you'll with Disney for,
for,
we can watch these,
these nobles and they agree to be junior partners of absolute rule.
Uh,
and they weren't the only ones.
And,
and the great power struggles of the 18th century,
uh,
would be very different than the,
than these,
uh,
this blood letting of civilians that it proceeded.
They professional kinds of armies and all of that.
But those are more themes,
uh,
for,
future lectures.
Now,
Wednesday I'm going to talk about exceptions to absolutism.
What the Dutch and what the English had in common that gave them very different
outcomes,
political outcomes.
And that's important too,
in the emergence of the country in which many of you live.
See Ya.